nous étions donc sur les trois ilets
nous rendions donc sur sur celle cher
donc on traverse la en travers sa rade
de fort de france et tout d'un coup
proche de je dirais un kilomètre à un
peu moins de milles nautiques de la delà
de celle cher il ya eu un gros choc en
mai monter dessus carrément on va dire
ça comme ça
voilà d'ailleurs l'impact en témoigne
pour pouvoir casser chose ce genre de
d'armature sachant qu'elle est faite
pour justement supporter des creux la
mer reste comment dirais-je quelque
chose de 2,2 très hostile on va dire il
faut que la mécanique tienne il faut que
tous tiennent d'abord pour pouvoir faire
ça un taux c'est que le choc était
particulièrement violent
je pense qu'il ya eu collision d'après
la d'après les stigmates laissés sur le
bateau c'est un bateau qui m'a pris de
face voilà voilà voilà qui complètement
complètement surpris par le choc on
n'avait pas vu venir
absolument pas absolument pas c'est le
c'est l'impression d'avoir reçu un coup
de coup de bâton derrière la tête on le
voit pas venir ce coup de bâton sinon
évidemment se protègent la tête
donc ça a été ça a été le cas ça a été
le cas en tout cas sûre sur le bateau
aussi en tout cas sur le mien et ça a
été donc un moment très très difficile
avec un blessé assez sérieux et ça va
tout va très très vite donc je réitère
dans ce que j'ai ce que j'ai ce matin en
disant qu' il ya eu délit en fait il ya
eu il n'y a pas eu délit proprement dit
sauf que moi je vais urgence il fallait
que j'aille tout de suite donc rapatrié
donc mon ami donc sur sur le malecon ou
où j'allais pris contact déjà avec les
autorités le cros hague qui bien sûr a
déclenché comme nous on est formé pour
ça ce qui gère après tout la sécurité la
patrie rapatriement sanitaire etc etc et
donc
une fois arrivé là bas évidemment la
sécurité d'abord du navire suite au choc
évidemment la première chose c'est
mettre le navire en sécurité donc
déclenché ces pompes on ne sait pas si
on a des voies d'eau aussi quoi voilà et
après bien sûr appelé le cross qui eux
après on déclenche et donc les pompiers
pour pouvoir récupérer donc cette
personne ayant un trauma un traumatisme
facial donc vous découvrez qu'il y ait
un blessé très sérieux qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous constatez le réflexe
de tout capitaine c'est de pouvoir
comme je vous l'aï dit à l'instant
mettre d'abord sont battus en sécurité
et après s'occuper du rapatriement
sanitaire sanitaire au plus vite ce qui
a été fait ça a été fait dans les
secondes qui suivent est donc l'impact
avait craint pour la vie de votre ami ah
bon c'est toujours très délicat d'avoir
sachant qu'on est responsable de toute
personne dont un sur son bateau voilà je
suis formateur donc c'est mon bateau est
évidemment capitaine donc voilà donc
c'est la priorité nous sommes formés
pour ça